red stars um by god there's so many
things we could say about this episode
me just tons it goes in so many
different directions and so many toys
and turns and yes is probably like one
of those laid back episodes I've seen
actually I think they've done it's it
seemed very a just way to say oh there's
even more okay well which is weird cuz
of you like the the setup is it seems
like a lot would happen with it they go
to this like this sand city filled with
sand people but they're all they're
literally just saying they don't move or
anything and Jake accidentally ate all
this all the snacks and there with
Marceline
he also ate Marceline's red erasers so
she needs red or else she's gonna go you
know ballistic and turned into a monster
and stuff so Finn tries to go look for
red and she keeps talking about how
she's gonna eat Jake so eventually Finn
finds this what he thinks is a ruby but
he's very uniquely colorblind and this
thing that I got there's like a couple
thing I was almost like I don't know
it's almost like Tomb Raider and Indiana
Jones or saying yet to solve this
mystery through like this archaeology or
whatever um where if you hear like me by
the way it's storming I'm sure you put
that together but and there's this guy
that turned always people to saying but
he's like dead he's a skeleton and this
other guy was sending this beam of light
to him to turn everybody into sand
and he's been doing it for something
like five hundred years yeah I think
really really long cuz he space nowadays
like oh man well don't need this emerald
anymore didn't keep saying it's a ruby
so whatever he takes it they say goodbye
goes back up turns out is an emerald cuz
Finn can only see red and gray no no he
can't
oh yeah who does that colorblind work
against these greens as Reds or yeah it
seems like okay so so this backpack must
be a red to him so which is kind of
confusing because then when you go to
the episode
marceline eat all the red wouldn't he be
like well no you're eating green clearly
you're eating green or whatever but I I
don't know that maybe adipic I don't
know but but then it's okay because
people's comes in in this giant sand
worm and Marceline kind of eats people's
a little bit or at least sucks out a
little bit of her red but thankfully
they got the spoon of was it reaches 30
at the spoon of prosperity which she
puts on her nose and that fully brings
her back to normal and then they leave
it I don't think what even to say about
it cuz it's like on the one hand it's
like it's hard to say oh that was a
total waste ur that was pointless or
something cuz it's like I still like
hanging with these people it's like you
put one there
like when Finn's just talking to that 3i
thing I mean there's yes just finding
out I don't have them I hold it kind of
sucks it's like well I really want that
Ruby man says there's still such a
likable attitude to them that even when
they're not doing much I still like just
hanging with them um you know I sir like
when Marceline was transforming and
getting more creepy looking so I thought
that was fun I love that that worm thing
that comes in that people's is rising
and worm
yeah the same worm um I love how all the
stuff is connected to her I just always
love like you know yours how does this
work how does her inventions work inside
just love that um I don't gets an
invention was it an actual like yeah I
guess it did sort of have like a tongue
and everything didn't I think it's an
actual creature that she just conquered
or tea or did she created into her brain
yeah so that would kind of make sense
completely possible but yeah so I mean
I'm mostly watching it like okay when is
something gonna happen when are we gonna
get to something really because I didn't
laugh too hard during this episode
either but I don't know if for some
reason I just I didn't mind it because
it just sort of seemed like a very
laid-back and whatever kind of episode
um and those once in a while are okay so
sort of depending on how they're spaced
out and here also
like yeah okay I'll take it over your
topics I liked when Jake like kind of
turned the like page and started was
like oh I'm gonna cook you instead
mm-hmm that kind of funny I liked his
reasoning - you're gonna eat me but
you're gonna eat me yeah - survival of
the fittest I guess I liked that um hi
Suze morning just to know what Finn was
doing them this whole Jake and Marcie
thing like it was interesting and all up
and I was like watching Vinge's going
through it I psycho that's kind of neat
what whoa what's that over there hey
stay out of the red okay
whoa what's that you know I was way more
interested in that but yeah and again I
think part of that is too because it was
just so laid back even talking to these
clearly dead or maybe not dead way you
know he had to ask if they're dead which
is now a very valid question in this
world because there's so many times
where it's like yeah it's probably a
good thing to ask honestly cuz you never
know again knowing this world they would
probably answer honestly yeah so yeah I
think I did enjoy that more and yeah the
Marceline Jake stuff like it was it it
was cute but yeah it sort of it dragged
on a bit you know and that like like I
said this episode didn't have too many
funny things in it but it like I said it
I felt it was it was okay as long as
like the episode before the episode
after aren't the same thing you know
it's like alright next episode I like to
see something happen or episode for this
was box prints yeah yeah I guess we had
a week let that settle - so maybe you're
right maybe this was a bad came after
box I'm gonna be like you know the way
back whatever yeah so I think a lot of
it if they didn't have yeah bad whole
civilization of sand people and the
setup and the guy down there he comes
across here I think you're right I think
I was just bailing well I was pointless
or whatever but that that was just
intriguing enough and now
just interesting enough and creative
enough I'm like okay yeah I I wanna
what's going on here and I'm strangely
enough kind of glad I don't know either
it's sort of like you know left to your
imagination I can continue with later or
whatever so yeah just a very yeah I just
like when Finn got the spoon from Marcy
though like yeah yeah so yeah I I don't
know like I said and this is I guess in
a strange way an episode like this
really is a testament to good characters
because I can watch them almost pretty
much do nothing and still kind of be
okay
you know cuz I just like I just like
watching them that much you know you
bring up a very good point with that you
know yeah you're right I was okay
watching it I wasn't like god I can't
stand this but now I think you're right
really good writing or really good
characters you can actually watch them
fix a truck this is system or yeah just
do I saw what you did there yeah oh oh
oh yes yes you do have something I got a
Father's Day gift from the best daughter
ever Oh
if Gunther yes and it's an official one
actually see I think it's an official oh
come on yeah
yes this is uh my daughter's fathers day
gift to me it's a protector for my phone
which if you look at my phone
it is completely destroyed on like so
many levels it's not even funny but yes
best honor ever
but now cool down well protected yes
that's it I'm done
my my Ice King goes into the Mad Hatter
for some reason we're gonna have a very
merry unbirthday party oh my goodness
you made her laugh yes I'm good at
making kids that by gnter protectors
laughs don't your protectors don't like
a condom for Gunter let me just go
through which is the whole thing that
covers him well don't you know
let's just give up on them and make free
Wow how it works but she's gonna crap
yourself over there come on let's go
with the whole routine together - I know
- did you know what about how the Ice
King did the Mad Hatter